ah je te vois je crois je crois que
c'est toi je crois que c'est toi la wii
c'est toi encore q comme tu es sexy dr
yo tourner s'excuse aujourd'hui on se
retrouve si on reste avec jojo tu as lu
tout le monde c'est du monde et on vient
juste de passer à peu près 30 minutes à
se trouver autant vous dire qu'on est
plutôt content même si il est totalement
ridicule
regardez le quoi l'homme ridicule donc
c'est dans ce jeu tu mets 40 secondes à
fabriquer quatre ans vrai tu mettrais
combien de temps peut-être deux jours et
demi voilà qu'on voit la chasse à l'ours
se jetant à wade direct monga dire l
ouïe ses deux flèches et amour c'est ça
quand tu flèche cc sparta tu viens
manger tu vas manger ou pas j'arrive ppc
rester le steak haché charal tu as
l'impression d'être en couple quand tu
vois votre chéri tu sais que tu peux te
faire des amis ou s'il bat toi tu peux
tu peux t'en faire parce que voir torse
comme ça c est ta tête de dépressif
c'était extrêmement au bloc j'ai envie
de te casser la pierre sur ton crâne
chauve voyage voilà donc je vais me
fabriquer une veste ont tué 28 secondes
à fabriquer une veste
je pense qu'il ya peu près comme ça
[Rires]
entouré des ours et des loups fait
subitement tu vois c'est bon tu défaite
vient dire au revoir à mon torse poil et
malheureusement je ne peux pas voir à
quoi je ressemble c'est le problème de
vivre la préhistoire c'est aux haïtiens
à l'arc
sauf toi sauf toi lucas au vu des
cabanes de la surprise tous avaient voté
le blocage des deux touchés et voilà
parce que dans le jeu on dépèce pas
d'animal avec un couteau ou un truc
coupant avec une pierre et on sent le on
sent le made in même pas china tu vois
en dessous en dessous de shylock quoi en
même temps un passe plat c'est un jeu où
nous sommes nous avons absolument rien
tu as tu es tellement sexy quand tu
coupe du bois je cherche près mais je
pourrais mettre une musique érotique ce
serait parfait quoi
c'est un problème mental quoi est-ce que
c'est mieux comme ça oh oh je tombe
amoureux il arrive quelquefois laisse
moi faire ou non floutées est un peu
d'air je souffre je regarde sa tête
regarde sa tête pour les as l'air
extrêmement mort quoi j'ai envie des
gens et j'ai même envie de lui donner
haricots la tire une flèche sur une
flèche sans qu'ils aient touché perdre
je loupe et un maire doit aussi il se
rapproche de jeu ouais mais mère jane
foley
ce geste est inquiète ce cher je dis
rien dire comme idée loriane farès il
bosse au visage et un train de chier
dessus débitons sa viande
va-t'en va-t'en luca luca va t'en fous
tu n'avais pas de problème si on regarde
ce qui me suit oui eh bah direction la
cabane c'est moi je les ai eus dans la
narine gauche avait là on est trop beau
mais qu'on a on avait eu des steaks on
pourrait faire leur barbecue party avec
avec tous mes abonnés que tournera steak
bon jojo en exclusivité voici que je
veux te séduire
je me fabrique un casque en cuir j'ai
hâte de voir ta tête avec le casque est
ce que est ce que tu fais plutôt motards
s'excite c'est un peu des années 80 avec
le que le tout conduire et tout ou alors
est ce que tu fais plutôt bonnet de bain
quand je le mets il ferme sa braguette à
tort qu'en lever ses potes aussi les iep
est ce qu'il ya des fermetures aux
bottes n'importe quoi à temps mais qu il
y avait un bruit à côté de moi attaquer
ou quoi jojo oui il ya un bruit il ya
des bruits à côté de moi c'est moi qui
te tirer des profits tu es un mec tu
m'as fait peur mais si tu parlais pas
j'étais sous pression de l'estac qui
vont être cramé jojo au fait ils peuvent
crever non non ah [ __ ] rassuré jean
c'est limite c'est plus un jeu de survie
c'est un jeu de cuisine gourmet le steak
23 secondes et demi après l'avoir mieux
mais c'est quoi ces chaussures mais
c'est dégueu à baisser vraiment fait
maison quoi toi je t'amène à cochons
lucas là c'est un peu allez on va le
dresser à l'est l'asie via le fait faire
demi-tour à temps au plateau d'argent en
espèces
c'est toujours très bon c'est vraiment
ridicule d'ailleurs veut apparemment ne
jamais faire une maison en plein milieu
de la route comme ça sur ce jeu parce
que c'est un pays un jeu pvp un sac à la
base ça là et là les mecs qui nous
cherchent eux marla disons qu'on est
gris là où la route
il ouvre la porte puis savez il se passe
ce à quoi à la la je sens qu'il y a des
ennemis par ici au une maison attention
enfin à culoz mais qui fabrique la
cabane qui peut la l'ouvrir à la ferme
et tu peux mettre un quad aussi sur les
portes
d'accord il y avait déjà des cheats
codes y avait des interphones aussi ou
bien sympa les rochers là ça fait très
proche est là
l'anecdote nul par jour fin 2014 c'était
déjà des leggings à l'époque en fait foi
sa tâche dans les faits ce que bon c'est
plus sacs plastiques que les guides non
petit déhanché et il faut pas fabriquer
chez pas à scooter un truc
ouais bah comme le pire a fêté une
voiture de la poudre un cadeau de ses
chefs l'avaient faire ouais j'ai
tellement peur que d'autres joueurs de
tombe dessus et nous défoncer moyens
battant je veux dire on a quand on a
quand même des sacs plastiques pour nous
protéger sur le corps déjà les balles
nous ferons rien tâchons jojo tu te fais
attaquer mon gars aurais tu arrêtes
[ __ ] heureusement doute et à temps
fort combien tu perds de vie pour rick
hansen one shot dans la nuque
s'intéresse à lui et le club salue le
salut des âmes en fait d'un gâteau au
chocolat tel qu'il est dans tout et
musique tu sais quoi mon ami kerouanton
pardon je t'appelle fait mal
excuse moi tu auras tu travailles pas tu
a réveillé quelque chose dit deux
[Rires]
dangereux psychopathe que hay follow you
did ces bébés alors par contre en tant
qu est bénie style n'y a pas de problème
te fais dix planches de bois en 20
secondes
c'est comme ça et son marteau va
peut-être voir faire des steaks en
passant oui avec j'adore que je ne fais
systech au total ouais ouais juste
oeuvrons fois j'ai fait faire des
courses quand même ce que je sais pas
moi j'aurais pu raid à manger chez moi
madame il cherche le cochon dans le jeu
je vois de la lumière la baule moi j'ai
rien savoir qui est là bas quand même
avec les steaks
regardez vous faut qu'on bouffe l'info
qu'on bouffe make way j'en ai déjà mangé
mois
attends maintenant patata pour manger
fisto non en quoi cela mais je crois que
c'est un hôtel ici mais tu crois que
c'est un hôtel c'est l'heure d'attaquer
c'est ça oui bienvenue à laisser partir
en courant vite fait et c'est un mec à
comment je kiffe raymond gars et la
sarah guetta peau et à voir mais qui
sont des gros tu penses toi qu'on le
verrait là c'est avec dedans sûr qu'il
est dambre on peut pas voir à travers le
bois la suisse a estimé que quand tu
vois que tu le vois on va l'attendre
on peut pas casser sa maison ah oui mais
qu'il a même fait une barricade devant
sa maison gros on ne l'aura jamais il
est trop bien caché ma un mot de passe
tout près lucas la porte 7 8 9 1
ok voilà c'est bon ils ont reculé la
surprise tiens tiens tiens j'ai du sang
partout enfin bon c'est bon c'est bon
j'ai du sang pour toi regal voila c'est
direct cette petite vidéo sur eux et
j'espère que ça vous aura plu on se
retrouve dimanche aux nouvelles vidéos
qui est le monde
et j'entends des cris doha et moi et
c'est pas écrit comme ça non mais en
fait c'est un mec dans le placard il
emporté le maïs est récurent
dans son placard par la limited est
figée dans sa mairie de la ville c'est
tout c'est ridicule